The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, we're
showing just a very short
video I just wanted
you to hear.
And we're going to be talking
about Pratham today.
We've had a very long
relationship with Pratham over
the years, we being J-PAL.
That is me and Professor
Banerjee and
several graduate students.
And one of the leaders of is
this person, Rukmini Banerji
And it's sort of useful
to hear this.
It's a very short segment where
she explains a little
bit what she sees the education
problem being about.
And then we'll take
it from there.
[VIDEO WITHHELD]
PROFESSOR: So I kind of wanted
to take one lecture to go in
detail to all of our work with
Pratham, not only because I
think Pratham is an amazing
organization, but also because
it will expose you to how we
learn about the problem, how
we build from one evolution to
the next, one project to the
next, how one project is
bringing some more questions
then we started with, and how
the next project tries to get
at these questions, also how the
partnership with the local
partners develops and
works and all that.
And to this, we are going to be
talking about this quality
problem, where we are trying
to address the basic point
that she makes.
Kids are in school.
At the moment, she talked at the
Clinton Global initiative,
that was 90%.
But the enrollment rates
are even higher
now, close to 100%.
In some districts, it's more
than 100%, because some of the
five-year-olds also go to
school, because that's kind of
a convenient way to
get babysitting.
But despite that, the
achievement is low.
She did point out the results
from the ASER survey.
So every year, since 2005,
Pratham puts together teams of
people, local people,
who go from local
universities, et cetera.
And they go in every single
district in India.
How many districts did she
say there was in India?
She mentioned it
at some point.
You see that everything
[INAUDIBLE]
if you are listening
to the video.
She said it at some point, how
many district they work in and
how many districts they have.
If I'm not mistaken, she said
something like 600.
So they are sending people to
every district in India, teams
of college students, local
volunteers, et cetera.
They have a sampling.
Of course they don't go
to every village.
But they do a sample
in each district.
And they administer a very
simple test of reading skills
and math skills.
So the reading skill test
looks like a page.
On the left side, you have
a very simple story.
Like she said, I go to school.
My brother goes to school.
We like going to school.
On the right side, you will
have single words and then
single letters.
First, you start the child
with a very simple story.
If they can do that, you bring
them to a slightly longer
story and try to measure
their comprehension.
If they come to the very simple
story, you ask them to
read a word.
If they can't read a word, you
ask them to read a letter.
So you, in this way, classify
your child as a nothing
reader, a letter reader, a word
reader, a small paragraph
reader, or a story reader.
And the simple, small paragraph
reader is what you
should be able to do at the
end of the first grade.
And what they find is, on
average, in 2005, that about
35,000 children, aged 7 to 14,
most of them are in school and
could not read a grade 1
paragraph and 60% could not
read a grade 2 story.
So these are numbers on one
of the ASER survey.
So blue is better in the maps
I'm going to show you.
And this is the fraction of kids
who are out of school.
And so that's quite a blue map,
because there are not
very many kids who are
out of school.
And the colors here
are the same.
This is now the reading
ability.
This is the fraction of
kids who can read a
standard one text.
So it is the fraction of kids
who can read or understand one
text among the kids who
are enrolled in
standard three to five.
So among children who are
enrolled in standard three to
five, how many of them can read
this grade one paragraph?
And you can see that
now we have a lot
of red in this card.
The red is a bit distributed
in different places, but
mostly it's quite red.
If you know India, does this map
look like what you would
expect for any social indicator
within India?
For anyone who knew India or
about India, because this is a
question that you might not
know the answer to.
So it doesn't really, because
the folklore in India-- and if
you look at immunization, that's
really what you get--
is that sort of the bad states
are these ones, Uttar Pradesh,
Bihar, Rajasthan, Jharkhand.
These are what they call the
BIMARU state, Bihar,
Rajasthan, Uttar Pradesh.
This is like where you have a
lot of boys and not very many
girls, suggesting infanticide
or selective abortion.
This is where you have very
low immunization rate, bad
outcomes, of course,
as I mentioned.
And these are the good states,
Andhra Pradesh, Karnataka,
Tamil Nadu, Kerala.
Kerala is, in particular, one of
Amartya Sen and John Rawls'
favorite states for its
successful education.
Kerala does well here, almost
everyone can read.
But what is surprising is
you have Tamil Nadu.
They're very proud
of themselves.
A lot of the kids are in
school, et cetera.
It's very red.
Less than half the kids enrolled
in [INAUDIBLE] three
to five cannot read
a sentence.
So that upset the government
of Tamil Nadu a great deal.
So when the first ASER report
came out, they didn't believe
the result.
That is not possible.
They went ahead and did their
own test, but they found the
same thing again.
So this suggests that there
is something different.
It's not only like disorganized
places that are
unable to deliver
to their kids.
Their is something maybe
deeper than that.
And Bihar did surprisingly
well in not being at the
absolute bottom of the
barrel in this graph.
So Bihar was happy.
Another thing that's is maybe
even more troubling is this
survey has been done from 2005
to 2010, every year.
It's been released in January
every year, on the Republic
Day in India.
And there is no progress.
So India is progressing across
all these dimensions, becoming
richer, there are fewer
poor people.
We're seeing they're eating less
and less, which is not
progress, per se.
But education, nothing,
no progress.
Also troubling is it's not
an Indian exception.
Surveys very similar to ASER
have been done in Kenya and
Uganda and Tanzania
and in Pakistan.
And they all find similar
kind of things.
A lot of children are in school,
most of them can't
read anything.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Is there still
progress across the board on
average, like in the nation?
Or the states are
static as well?
PROFESSOR: So you're
exactly right.
That's a very good question.
It's no progress across the
board in the nation, but the
states are not static.
Some states start doing well
for a while, and means some
states are moving down
to compensate.
So, for example, in the
last report, 2010,
Punjab had a big progress.
So that's one of the things they
are trying to look at is
why is Punjab suddenly
progressing?
What are they doing
that is different?
And I'm going to be able to
talk a bit about that.
And in fact, in the Punjab
example, what they seem to be
doing that is different is
really to try to insist on
these core competencies
in the schools.
They have a period of time,
every school day, two hours a
day, which are devoted to
teaching the kids at whatever
level they are forgetting
the curriculum.
And that is what they think is
the reason why Punjab is
progressing.
So what we are going
to do today is--
do we have evidence to suggest
that, in fact, they're right?
And that is the key problem and,
therefore, the key of the
success of Punjab.
Meanwhile, some other state,
like Uttar Pradesh, would be
going down.
Ben?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Is the student to teacher
ratio more or less?
I know these states are huge.
But are they more or less
the same across
the different states?
PROFESSOR: So it's a
very good question.
I think, they are, probably,
generally
more or less the same.
And they are not horrible.
Because, actually, being a
teacher is not a bad job.
So there are a number of
teachers who are available.
So you don't have the very,
very, large class size that
you have, for example, in a
country like Kenya, where,
after free primary education,
the class size in grade one
was easily 70 to 80 children
per classroom.
You have less of
that in India.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So it seems like the
enrollment is high, but do
they also track that the
attendance is high?
PROFESSOR: So that's a
very good question.
And the answer is that, yes,
they check attendance.
And attendance is low.
So attendance is low, both for
teachers and for children.
So in Bihar, for example, we
have a survey of children's
attendance.
The rate of absence is between
30 to 50% for kids.
And we've done the same
thing in several
countries of the world.
Generally, children's absence
is very, very high.
So kids are enrolled, but
they don't show up.
And it's not that they
are ghost enrollees.
This 30% attendance is not
concentrated across 30% of
kids who never come.
It's every child who is absent
one day, coming one day,
absent on day, coming one day.
And that is one problem.
So we have a lot of absence
of children.
And we have a lot of absence
of teachers as well.
So a survey was done in four to
five developing countries,
by the World Bank,
including India.
They found a very large
teacher absence rate.
So in India, it was about
25% absence rate.
And that's about what ASER found
as well, of teachers.
So you show up to a school
during school hours, and you
have three of four
teachers who are
actually in the school.
The second problem is that once
they are in the school,
it is not a given that they
are actually teaching.
So another one out of these four
teachers is actually in
school but not teaching.
There was a funny report, a few
years ago, describing what
they were doing, ranging from
drinking tea to drawing
political posters.
The reason being that a lot
of these teaching jobs are
patronage jobs, which are
filled by the political
parties, so they need to draw
their posters sometimes.
So that means that the teachers
are present teaching
half the time.
The students are, themselves,
present about half the time.
That means the students get
about a quarter of the time
that they should get in
front of a teacher.
This is a where, [? Hookman's ?]
point, that
you need a bit of time of
student-teacher interaction to
get teaching.
It actually becomes
quite pertinent.
Yep, sorry?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the standard curriculum.
What kind of things
does it teach?
Is there any [INAUDIBLE]
benefits from it?
Are there any kids who are
up to the curriculum?
PROFESSOR: So that's a
very good question.
What is the curriculum?
So the curriculum in India--
and that actually is true in
the countries I know--
tends to be very ambitious.
And there are various
reasons why those
curriculum are very ambitious.
They are probably more ambitious
than what is being
taught in the US.
Actually, significantly more
ambitious than what is being
taught in US primary schools.
We once showed up to a school.
We were with the Pratham team.
The visit was announced.
The teacher wanted
to look good.
And his idea of looking good was
to draw things like that
on the board, in this grade
three class, so all the kids
were like looking around.
And it doesn't mean that this is
what he actually does on a
day in day out basis, but
it means it is what
they suggest to do.
So it's not necessarily
a bad curriculum.
In fact, India has a lot of
good, very good, very serious
education experts who are
thinking about educating the
child to a real, true
understanding of science.
But for most of the children,
it's completely above their
head, very quickly.
And then some of the children
benefit from it.
We can see an example of
that very quickly.
We'll see an example of
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Is their proficiency
in math as bad as in
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It tends
to be worse.
So math is a bit worse
than reading.
For example, if you look at
division, which is the
equivalent of your standard two
kid, you have like 20% of
kids can do division.
So that's where we are.
So this quality of education,
I was saying the other day,
has not concerned the policy
establishment, very much, for
many years.
The policy establishment has
been more concerned about
getting as many children as
possible in schools, enrolled
in schools.
With the understanding that,
oh, if we can manage to get
them in schools, somehow
learning will happen.
And the Turkey experiment is,
in a sense, an archetypal
example of that, which is
let's make education
compulsory, let's have boarding
schools, let's have
buses that are going to
bring the kids to
the boarding school.
And then black box,
learning happens.
You have an educated child.
But it's been about 10 years
since academics have been a
bit puzzled at that.
And looking at the quality of
education saying, how do we
make education actually work?
What's important?
And the first thing that jumps
at you, when you go to a
school in India, in Kenya, even
in rural Morocco, which
is a richer country,
is that there is
nothing in the school.
The school is usually
very bare.
You have fewer desks
than students.
People are bunching like
three to a desk.
They will usually have a
blackboard, very few
textbooks, and, of course,
nothing like computers and
things like that.
So the first generation of
studies was about, well, they
have none of that.
How can they learn?
Maybe what they need
is more material.
And in fact, when the idea of
randomized evaluation started
to be applied to development,
Michael Kremer, who is a
professor at Harvard, wanted to
do a demonstration project,
wanted to show that it is
possible to do a randomized
evaluation.
And it's interesting.
And he wanted, for demonstration
purposes, an
example where it would clear
that it has an effect.
And so he asked around,
et cetera.
And he found out that what would
be obvious is textbooks.
In Kenya, no one
has textbooks.
If only we give textbooks to the
kids, obviously, they are
going to learn better.
So that was his first example
that he chose, which was
chosen specifically to
demonstrate success.
And running his experiment, he
was learning how to do an
experiment at the same time.
So his first experiment was
very small, 14 schools, 7
treatment, 7 control,
and found no effect.
He thought about it, and he
said, oh well, of course, it's
because I have so few schools.
And you remember, when you have
schools, you need to take
into account, when you calculate
your standard error,
that all these children
are similar.
So he said, oh well, my
experiment is not big enough.
So let's take a bigger
sample of schools.
He took 100 schools.
He took half of them and
again found no effect.
So there he thought, well, maybe
the test is too hard.
I'm using the test,
the normal test.
Maybe that is too hard.
Let me use a different test that
is going to be able to
discriminate progress even
at a lower level.
And he got his experiment
started.
And again, he found no effect.
So there he started saying maybe
there is no effect, even
in a larger sample, even
with a better test.
So maybe there is no effect.
So eventually, what he found is
that, if you focus on the
children, who were already doing
well at the baseline,
then they benefit from
the textbooks.
So that's a very long winded
answer to your question, which
is there are children who
benefit from the curriculum
and, therefore, benefit
from the textbooks.
But it's a small minority.
And the explanation he gave is
the textbooks are in English,
which makes sense, because the
curriculum in Kenyan schools
is in English.
But a lot of children don't even
speak English, because
English is their
third language.
They first speak their mother
tongue, the local language.
Then they learn Swahili in
the first few grades.
And then English is introduced
in grade one as a language,
and then as a language of
instruction from grade three
or grade four.
But the problem is that because
the kids aren't
actually learning effectively,
by the time they reach grade
five or six, they actually don't
know English, so the
textbooks are of no use.
So exposed, it could
be understood what
was going on here.
And then they tried
a bunch of stuff.
Flip charts also
have no effect.
Cutting the class size in two,
if you make no other
differences, also
has no effect.
And a little bit worrisome,
things like the deworming
program, which increases
attendance, but it didn't
increase test scores.
So it seemed that these
extra school
days also had no effect.
So changing inputs
just didn't work.
So maybe it's a problem that is
just incredibly difficult.
So we were there a
few years ago.
So what this common with all
this intervention is that they
are just changing the inputs.
They are doing more of the same,
adding more textbooks,
adding more teachers, adding
more resources.
But they are no change to the
pedagogy and no change to the
incentives.
So no one is given incentives.
The teachers are not
given incentives.
The students are not
The parents are not
given incentives.
And the pedagogy and the
curriculum stays the same.
So that's kind of where we were
about five, six years
ago, a little bit depressed.
Picture us, this was our first
set of randomized experiments
and nothing works.
So we were thinking, maybe, this
is going to be the end of
randomized experiments,
because you can't be a
doomsayer forever, otherwise
people really hate you.
So that's why we were
a little bit sad.
Rukmini came to visit us,
shortly after that happened, a
few years after the
establishment of Pratham, came
here to MIT.
Because a former MIT student
had gone to work
for them as an intern.
A former undergraduate
student of ours had a
relationship with them.
So Pratham started in 1994.
At that time, it was established
by UNICEF to help
some kids in Bombay.
It would be your typical, small
NGO doing some work in
Bombay, particularly what they
call bridge classes.
Which is take a kid who is out
of school, give them a course
for a few months so that they
can try and go back to their
regular school.
That's what they were doing.
But they were ambitious.
So there was the Rukmini that
you heard and Madhav Chavan
wanted to make a real
difference.
So since then, they're
grown substantially.
They've reached millions and
millions of children.
I think there are about 38
million children, who are
reached by the Pratham program,
one way or the other,
so about half the population of
France, overall population
of France, just in
terms of scale.
And so that's the largest
non-governmental organization
to do education in India,
probably in the world.
And their motto is "every child
in school"-- that half
of the world would
agree with them--
"and learning well"--
is where, maybe, they have
a little difference.
So they came to us towards
the beginning.
And that's the reading
that read for today.
They wanted to evaluate the
Balsakhi program, which was
the flagship program
at the time.
Balsakhi means the friend
of the child.
So the Balsakhi is a young
woman, from the
community, so an adult.
Like she said, you need
some adult time.
Barely an adult, some
18-year-old, usually having
only high school education,
so grade 10 to 12.
And Pratham would give them a
very short training and then
dump them into the school,
with which they had an
agreement with the teachers that
the school would let them
pull out the kids who were
lagging behind in grade three
of in grade four.
So why is this a good
demographic, the 18-year-old,
grade 10 educated woman?
Why is that a good goal
to work with?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: She's more familiar
with the community, so she can
probably relate to
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that is one reason
is that she is more
known to the community,
because she's local.
She's not much older.
And she's not intimidating or
scary for the parents, who,
maybe, can work better
with the kids.
That's a very good reason.
What's another reason?
AUDIENCE: I would say for
the teacher's as well.
Maybe the teachers are not as
intimidated that the balsakhi
will go and teach these
students some really
innovative thing that would
make [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So for the teachers, she might
be not very intimidating,
which will cut both ways.
On the one hand, it's
more easily
acceptable for the teachers.
On the other hand, there is a
tendency that teacher would
use the balsakhi to make
the tea or other
activities like that.
And we are going to see some
of that happening, not
actually in Baroda.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So she's locally
trained, which makes sense in
kind of [INAUDIBLE]
perspective.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
She is locally trained,
only for two weeks.
This is very cheap.
And there is another
aspect of the cost.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Not about the cost,
but she might be more
motivated to help the
[INAUDIBLE] children, because
it's not like this is a second
job she can perform.
It's not a fallback option.
It's something that she
wants to do that is a
period in her life.
It seems a bit time sensitive.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So she might be more motivated
for this reason.
Also for what you said earlier,
that she's close to
them, et cetera.
But also this is something that
she effectively chose to
do at this point and not
something that is just putting
money in a bank account.
AUDIENCE: She's not highly
qualified, so the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
She's not highly qualified,
so she's cheap.
What is another reason
why she is cheap?
Why don't these people go
and do something else?
AUDIENCE: Also there's a high
turnover in these [INAUDIBLE]
make a certain income to teach,
so you're not really
relying on this thing.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
quality of the teaching.
It doesn't have to be like a
small, really enthusiastic
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's easy to get
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They have high turnover, which
could be a plus or a minus.
On the minus side, of course,
you don't get the experience.
On the plus side, you
don't get tired.
And you don't rely on people
who have a huge vocation.
You rely on people getting
enthusiastic for one year.
So very much along the model
of Teach For America, where
you get MIT, graduating from
school, energetic about
wanting to do this.
A bit of what you're saying,
which is it's what I want to
do at this point in my life.
And then by the time you
don't want to do it
any more, you stop.
And there is one more thing
about them, specifically,
which makes them cheap.
AUDIENCE: Everything
about them.
I mean I think there's like a
good chance that they have
families or that they're part of
a family, and maybe that's
why they're stuck in the area.
And they don't necessarily
have the ability to go
somewhere else.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
That's a very important point.
Most of these women
are unmarried.
They are living at home.
They are sort of waiting
to be married.
And there is actually not
much they can do.
Because the parents won't
let them leave.
And mostly, their parents won't
let them work, because
working is not becoming for a
certain, sort of lower, middle
class category woman, waiting
to be married.
You shouldn't be like working.
You should be able to be--
it's not a good signal for the
family that they're not able
to provide for you
and all that.
But this is hardly
seen as working.
This is more like volunteering
and helping your community and
things like that.
So they can do that.
So they are sort of available.
So one part of the genius of
Pratham is that they identify
a group of people who
are actually sort of
available for free.
Here, they pay them, but in
future programs, that I'm
going to talk to you a minute
after, they're not even paid.
They are just unpaid.
They do that for a while.
And that get some, presumably,
other rewards of doing that,
which are more in the form of
intrinsic reward of seeing the
kid progress, and, therefore,
you also select people who are
motivated in that dimension
as one of you pointed out.
So that's all of the pluses.
The minuses you already
mentioned.
The turnover is one of them.
You can't get them to
get experienced.
The second minus is
that they're, of
course, much less educated.
Maybe there is some good reasons
why a teacher needs a
college degree.
Maybe it's actually terrible
to take the kid out of the
classroom to put them in front
of someone who knows nothing.
So that's kind of the
risk that would
potentially be there.
So that's the program.
And when they came to see us,
we were wondering how to
evaluate this program, with
them, in an experiment, in a
way that is not going to cause
a problem for them in the
city, that's not going to hinder
their work too much.
And that's experimental design
that we decided to
adopt in a new place.
So Vadodara and Gujarat, those
were places where they had not
worked at all.
Had about 100 schools.
A little more than 100 schools
divided in two groups,
randomly, with the
computer, group A
schools and group B schools.
The group A schools
got the balsakhi
for grade three children.
The group B schools
got the balsakhi
for grade four children.
So what's an advantage of this
design from the point of view
of political acceptability?
Why did we go like this, instead
of doing the more
standard thing, which would be
to say, well, in group A
treatment, and grade three and
grade four get the balsakhi
and group B, no one
gets a balsakhi?
AUDIENCE: Well, in a way, if you
don't give one group any
treatment at all, you're
almost sabotaging your
education [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sabotaging
is a strong word.
But exactly the idea is that
this allows you to be present
in every school.
So Pratham is not
infinitely rich.
They can easily argue-- and I
think that was very true at
that time-- that look,
we can give you one
balsakhi per school.
We can't afford more.
So you either put it in three
or you put it in four.
We can't give you both.
But at least every school
is being engaged with.
So they are engaged with
the system as a whole.
And no school is
disadvantaged.
That makes it easier for the
school system to say, yes,
they are just working with us.
They are part of us.
It also makes data collection
much easier, because you're
involved with everyone.
What is a potential danger
of this design?
The plus is what I just said.
What's the potential minus?
Since you have a balsakhi in
every school, what's the
potential minus?
AUDIENCE: They might not just
be teaching grade three.
The might be overlapping grade
three and four or something.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The balsakhi might take both
groups, so that your control
group becomes partly treated.
Or even if it's not the
balsakhi, the head teacher
might say, oh great, we have
a balsakhi for grade three.
So we're going to take the
teacher out of grade three and
use it to divide grade
four in two.
And so grade four would
be associated.
Or they could say, well, since
the grade three got the
balsakhi, when some other
organization comes with
computers, well, we'll put
them in grade four.
So there is a danger of
resources being reallocated
across grades in a way that
contaminates your treatment.
So fortunately, that was not
really an issue there, because
in Vadodara, the way the school
system is organized, a
school is made of one teacher
per grade, regardless.
Sometimes in the same school
building, you have more than
one school.
And that happens sometimes
in the US as well.
You have this charter school and
the regular school sharing
the same school building.
In Vadodara what happened is,
if it's a big school, it's
actually a big school building,
but under totally
separate administration.
So a school is made of five
teachers and a head teacher.
That's it.
So there is less scope for
reallocating, because you have
your one teacher anyway.
And they're also not very
imaginative in terms of using
the resources in the
most optimal way.
So that turned out not
to be a problem.
So the way we evaluated the
program is then by comparing
grade three, group
A's treatment
compared with control.
And in grade four, that's
the opposite.
We also worked in Bombay.
So that's the second year
we have asked a group.
So if you were a kid who was
in grade three, in group A,
you are treated in grade three
and then, again, you are
treated in grade four,
because you would
have moved one grade.
If you were a kid who entered in
grade four, you would never
be treated.
Or if you were a kid who entered
grade three in group
B, you also would never
be treated.
So we have kids treated one
year, kids treated two years,
and kids treated one year.
And then in Bombay, we did
something similar.
This is Shobhini She used
to work at Pratham.
And now she's one of the
executive director of J-PAL
South Asia.
You can say, hi, to her.
And in Bombay, we did something
similar, except we
started in grade two, three,
and then moved
it to three, four.
The reason why we switched is
that they realized that they
didn't have right pedagogy for
engaging with the grade two
children, that the grade two
children were too small, and
they didn't know how
to deal with them.
The initial plan was to do two,
three and then reverse
again, two, three.
And then they turned out that
they weren't happy with
they're grade two, so they
moved three, four.
So that's kind of the idea.
So this is the design.
So in principle, now, we could
say, well, they're good.
We have the designs.
Now, all we need to do is to
compare treatment and control
after one year and after
two years, and
we're going to be done.
But unfortunately, when you run
real experiments, you get
real problems.
I've yet to meet an experiment
where there was no problems.
And this was, at least,
my first big one.
So we had a lot of problems
that I want to talk about.
The first one is the way to
evaluate the program was to
administer a test
in the school.
And we had some issue
with the test.
The first one is that,
as I was saying, a
lot of kids are absent.
And if we only tested the kids
who were present in school, we
have some attrition.
Maybe in urban India,
absenteeism is less bad, but
maybe 20% of kids are absent on
a given day, so they don't
take the test.
So why is that potentially a
problem to have missing kids
in the test?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the kids that
are absent are those that are
more likely to not [INAUDIBLE]
class, and so they either
chose or their parents chose
that, maybe, they could better
use that time working
from home.
And so all the results
are biased.
Then you're only really
testing the kids that
understand more and you're
ignoring the kids that
understood the least.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that could be the first
problem, which is those kids,
whom we are testing, they are
not representative, because
maybe they're the one who
understand the most.
And that could lead to an even
bigger problem, because
suppose the intervention is
effective and most kids now
understand better.
Then what could happen with the
attrition in the treatment
group versus the
control group?
Now you all know very well,
it's the kids who don't
understand who don't come.
And now the kids who understand
better are in the
treatment group.
What might happen
to attrition?
AUDIENCE: The attrition would
be less for the students who
are in the treatment group.
PROFESSOR: The attrition would
be less for students who are
in the treatment group.
And the kids who are coming
tends to be the weaker kids.
So now we are comparing the
strong kids in the control
group to the strong kids plus
some of the weak kids in the
treatment group.
So that will tend to make our
estimate look smaller relative
to what it should be.
Because now we have a different
population of
students in the treatment
and control groups.
So we have a bias here.
It goes in the direction of
not finding an effect.
So if we still find an
effect, we're happy.
But it's not the
right estimate.
So to solve this problem,
what did we do?
Did we rely, uniquely, on
the test in the school?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You found the kids,
even if they happened to be at
home or elsewhere and
administrated the test
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We went and looked
for them, wherever they were,
except if they'd left
for the village.
So the attrition ended up being
low, less than 10%, and
similar, now, in treatment
and control school.
Because it's not because people
don't understand that
they leave for the village.
It's because they have something
to do there.
So that was the first thing.
The second problem we had is
that the testing instrument--
actually, not in year
1 but in year 0--
we designed a test which
was at grade level.
We designed a test to
test the curriculum.
So it's like, if this is what
should be tested, what's on
the board, here, we tested
at that level.
So if they were supposed to
learn Euclidean geometry,
that's what was tested.
And we had a big problem, which
is that the teachers
cheated like crazy.
So the reason we saw that
is that all of the
tests were the same.
So clearly, the teacher had
written the answer on the
board, and all the students
were copying down.
In one class, all the students
had the same name.
So the teacher clearly wrote the
name, like a sample name,
on the board.
And all the students dutifully
wrote down the name that they
saw on the broad.
So we said that's not working.
There is a paper by Steve
Levitt, who shows very subtle
things, how you can
detect cheating.
That was easy.
It didn't require a lot
of imagination.
It was pretty obvious that
cheated like crazy to make
their kids look better.
So we thought about how we
can solve this problem.
We are going to administer a new
test without the teacher,
that some special Pratham staff
is going to come to
administer the test.
And we did that.
And then we realized that
most of the students now
had 0 on the test.
So this test was way too hard,
which is why the teacher had
been cheating, because they
were a bit embarrassed.
So the solution here was to
develop a much easier test
that covered the competencies
starting from, can you write
your own name, to--
I don't know--
2 plus 2, finishing with a few
questions such as as, Nancy
goes to the market.
And she buys three onions
at 15 rupees.
And how much change does she
have, that kind of thing.
So that's the problems
that we had.
Further problems we had, we
had a problem in Bombay.
Because the second year of the
evaluation turned out to be
2002 to 2003.
Before that, September
2001 happened.
We were walking in a quite
Muslim neighborhood of Bombay.
A lot of kids were named like
Osama and things like that.
People were pretty upset about
the US at the time.
And so Pratham, maybe because
of us, maybe just it would
have been anywhere, was somehow
seen, maybe, as an
American presence.
So some schools said that
they don't want to
work with the program.
So about 30% of schools said
that they did not want to work
with the program.
Or, in another set of schools,
someone was identified, but
they couldn't read, themselves,
so they couldn't
really be entrusted to teach
reading to the kids.
So they also didn't do it.
So can we just drop all the
schools that refuse to
participate from the program?
Can we just drop them
from the analysis?
AUDIENCE: Well, that's
a selective bias.
There is a some reasons for
which they dropped, which make
them inherently different
from the other schools.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So we can't do that, because
that's a selection bias.
Maybe these are the weaker
schools who are
refusing the program.
Maybe they are the stronger
schools, because they are
independently minded.
Who knows?
But what is clear is that's
it's certainly not random.
So we lose random control
comparison.
So what we do?
Well, the first thing you can do
is to say, well, I'm going
to not measure the effect
of the balsakhi program.
I'm going to measure the effect
of my intention to
treat the schools with
the balsakhi program.
So we called that intention
to treat.
What an intention to treat is
a Pratham official coming to
the headmaster and saying,
hey, we have a
balsakhi for you.
So this, we can do in an
unbiased way, right?
Because if we compare all the
test scores in the school
where someone has come and
offered the program to the
test scores in the school where
no one has offered the
program, there is no
selection here.
But it's not the effect
of the program.
It's the effect of my attempt
to provide the program.
So that's why we call it
an intention to treat.
It's not the treatment effect.
It's the wishful thinking.
It's like my attempt
to treat you.
Now, I wrote, here, on the
board, if we wanted to know
the effect of the program itself
not the intention to
treat, we can divide the
intention to treat effect by
the fraction of schools who
accept the program.
So, for example, if 70% of
schools accept the program,
and we find an effect of 10 on
the test scores, a gain of 10
points in the intention to
treat, the intention to treat
is 10 points.
That's due to only 3/4
of the schools.
So we can blowup the estimate
by dividing by 3/4, which is
about multiplying by 1.25.
So instead of 10, the
effect is 12.5.
So this is what's called
a Wald estimate.
When you divide your intention
to treat by the fraction of
the take-up of the program,
which, here, we call that the
first stage.
So in the first stage, you offer
a program, and then some
fraction of people take it.
In the second stage,
that has an effect.
And the combination of the first
stage and the second
stage produces the intention
to treat.
So now to go from the intention
to treat the effect
of the program, you
do a scale-up by
dividing by the take-up.
So this is, in five sentences,
you're instrumental viable
estimate,
We could spend about a
whole semester on it.
There are conditions
under which this
is valid to do this.
There are conditions under
which this is not valid.
And this has interpretations
which vary.
So Josh Angrist, in the econ
department, is the one who did
most of the work on this.
So the point it that-- but think
of it in this simple
way, for this kind of
noncompliance problem--
is let's just normalize
the estimate by
dividing by the take-up.
It would also work if you have
some school in the control
group that managed to get
the balsakhi anyway.
Then you could divide by the
difference between the take-up
in the intention to treat group
and the intention not to
treat group.
So if 10% of schools manage to
get the program in the control
group, you would divide your
intention to treat by 27%
minus 10%, that's 65%.
And you would blow
it up that way.
What it amounts to doing is to
say, this is my estimate of
the effect of the program,
assuming that the only reason
why they're in the intention
to treat effect is because
those who might try to treat are
more likely to be treated.
So here are the results.
The results are expressed in
standard deviation of the
unique test scores.
What this means is that we take
the mean of the control
group and divide by the
standard deviation.
So the advantage of doing that--
maybe you can see that
more in recitation--
is that every education
program does that.
So we can compare our results
to what other people did.
For year one, this is the
standard deviation.
This is the test score in
treatment and the test score
in control.
That's the difference, 0.17.
That's the standard error of
this difference below.
So you divide one
by the other.
You get a t-stat of about 1.7.
So that's significant
but at a 10% level.
In year two, kids progressed.
And the difference
is much larger.
So you get an effect of 0.4
standard deviation in math and
a 0.25 standard deviation in
language and something similar
for the standard four classes.
So those are a large effect.
To scale that up, one of the
most famous education
experiments is the Tennessee
STAR class-size reduction
experiment, where that
reduced class-size in
Tennessee from 20 to 8.
It was very, very expensive
program that had an effect of
0.2 standard deviation.
So 0.2 is considered to be a
reasonably large effect.
Here, in the second year of the
program, we are way above
that for math.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: How big is the
standard deviation relative to
the average score?
PROFESSOR: So this is
all normalized.
So this is, in a sense,
already standardized.
This is already standardized
to the average and to the
standard deviation.
AUDIENCE: But there
is like a wide
distribution in the classroom?
PROFESSOR: You mean,
is it wide?
Yeah, so you can see, it's not
very wide, in this case.
Because the students are so
weak that, I think, the
distribution of test scores,
in terms of points, is not
that large compared to what
you could find elsewhere.
It's kind of a relatively
tight distribution.
So in terms of points,
it's useful.
There are other ways
to look at this
than standard deviation.
For example, the fraction of
kids who can do these kinds of
things, so in percentage
points.
How many more kids
can do division?
can do addition?
Which are also useful
to look at, which I
don't have with me.
That's a good point.
So these estimates are large,
but they're not very precise,
because there's a lot of
differences between kids.
And one thing that really helps
to control this noise is
to control for how good
where they before.
Because test scores
of children are
extremely stable over time.
The biggest predictor, sadly,
of how a child does is how
they did last year.
And so, when we control for
that, we get much more precise
results, which are here.
So these are a bunch
of results.
So this is the improvement in
year 1, for both cities
together, where we get an
improvement of 0.2 in math,
0.3 in language--
sorry, opposite, 0.2 in math in
year 1, 0.3 in math in year
2, for verbal, 0.7, not
significant in math, for
verbal, 0.7 for year
1, 0.15 for year 2.
And then we can look at various
aspects of it, where
we get a slightly bigger effect
for Vadodara and Bombay
but, generally, quite similar
results for math.
And language has bigger effect
in Vadodara than in Bombay.
Bombay starts from
a higher level.
But across the broad, except
with Bombay year two, you find
pretty large effects,
quite large effects.
So this is very different
from what we had
with the test scores.
Now, you might still wonder
that these are for all the
kids involved in the program.
And you might still wonder
whether the effect comes from
helping the lower achieving
kids, which is what you're
trying to do, or it's coming
from helping the higher
achieving kids by removing
these disturbing, lower
achieving kids from their
classroom for two hours a day.
That would be fine.
But the distributional effect
would be very different.
If the idea is that you just
send the kids to recess, and
they kind of hang-out, and
learn strictly nothing,
meanwhile, your 20, high
achieving kids progress, that
could give us those
mean effects.
But that is not necessarily
something that we would be
very excited about.
So for that, what is important
is then to look at what is the
effect by sub-group?
And what was the finding
when we looked at
sub-groups, who benefited?
AUDIENCE: The lowest one third
benefited the most.
PROFESSOR: The lowest one
And who was more likely
to go to the balsakhi?
Also the lowest one,
fortunately.
So when you look at the lowest
one, you start finding a
pretty large effect for the
bottom third and a much weaker
for the top third.
For example, if you look at
year 2, the effect for the
bottom 1/3 is 0.5 standard
deviation.
That's starting to be
a huge effect, 0.5
standard deviation progress.
0.3 for the middle
one, and 0.03 for
the top one, no effect.
And this is your chance
to go to the balsakhi.
So your chance to go
to the balsakhi
declines with the group.
So the point estimate of the
effect declines at about the
same rate as the point estimate
for the balsakhi.
So the next thing we did is a
little bit the same exercise
as adjusting the Bombay
estimate, to go from this
estimate of the effect of
putting a balsakhi in the
classroom, to are you going
to the balsakhi?
So basically, the effect, this
0.5 standard deviation, is due
to about 20% of kids
who are actually
going to the balsakhi.
Because there doesn't seem to
be an effect for the other
children, which we see from
looking at the pattern
declining as the pattern
of take-up declines.
So now you can divide
this 0.5 by 0.2.
And you get the effect for
people who go to the balsakhi
of one standard deviation, which
are very, very, very
large effects, in the education
literature.
And if you divide 0.32
by 0.16, you'll
also find about 1.
And this is, of course,
unsignificant.
But if you divided 0.4 by 0.06,
taking the estimate
seriously, again, you would find
the same type of effect.
So this is a program that was
highly effective, for kids who
were sent to the program, but
had no effect on the kids who,
in principle, should have also
benefited from the reduction
in class size.
So what did we learn?
We learned that it is possible
to make a lot of progress,
with a grade 10 educated woman
trained for two weeks.
And we also learned that
teachers are not very good at
exploiting freed-up resources.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: How much variability
was there between the
different thirds?
If the top third isn't that much
better off than then the
bottom third, then that would
say something different than,
if the top third is very well
educated whereas the bottom
third is really not.
PROFESSOR: So the bottom
third, basically, knows
nothing at all, for starters.
Like they can't do anything
at the beginning.
They can't recognize letters,
can't recognize numbers.
Whereas the top third is not
at grade level but can at
least do something.
So what I'm saying is not
that we shouldn't care
about the top third.
We should care about them.
But that program was really
targeted toward the bottom.
And so the big difference, in
the context of this program,
is that the top third didn't
get the benefit from the
program, because they weren't
sent to the program.
Except that there could have
been indirect benefits from
the fact that the teacher's
now have a much
smaller class size.
Instead of 40 kids of very
heterogeneous levels, they now
have 20 of better level.
So they could have adjusted
their teaching to do better by
these kids.
And it seems that they didn't.
So in terms of the whether
this is an optimistic or
pessimistic conclusion, it's
kind of the glass is half-full
or half-empty.
The half-full part is
you can do this.
It's reasonably easy to make
a lot of progress.
Perhaps because kids start from
such a low level, to go
back to your question,
initially.
If the standard deviation is
low, because everyone is at 0,
then it's easy to make
some progress.
And you're going to see
it very quickly.
On the other hand, the teachers
seem to not really be
using the resources in a way
that allows them to take
advantage of this.
So that's where we were
at the end of this.
And we had a bunch more
questions that
we wanted to ask.
What do we still need to know?
So suppose we would want to go
from this program to, say,
well, let's do a policy
for all of India.
What else do we need to know
before we move further?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The thing, for me, is
to understand what is the
relation between attendance and
how much those kids, those
programs are actually
effective?
Because, I mean, you showed that
enrollment, as a whole,
doesn't have too much
of an influence.
But maybe attendance
would help.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we could say, well, maybe
there are other things to look
at, children's attendance,
teacher's attendance.
Maybe the big difference
with the balsakhi is
that they were there.
Maybe that's just it.
Can we change their learning
just with incentives?
AUDIENCE: Also, maybe look
at the curriculum.
Maybe the reason why the
children are learning is
because the material is more
basic, whereas if you just
stay in the classroom, the
material is already too hard,
and you're not able to do it.
PROFESSOR: That's the
other big contender.
So you have both contenders.
One is, OK, the balsakhi
are actually there.
The kids are going.
That's why they are learning.
The second is that's not-- the
incentive to this is really
the pedagogy, which is about
the learning material.
And if we could train the
teachers to train at that
level, we would have
the same effects.
AUDIENCE: The cost effectiveness
of the program,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so we could
say, what's the cost
effectiveness in the city?
We could look at the cost
effectiveness elsewhere.
AUDIENCE: Also, it could be
interesting to see the effects
of having more strict, I
guess, passing policy.
Because a lot of kids are
advancing to the next grade
without actually
being prepared.
And maybe making that a little
bit more strict, so that they
don't go to next level until
they're actually prepared.
That could improve.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's a very good point.
In fact, the policy is not
strict at all at the moment.
Rukmini says it the short
video, everybody passes,
regardless.
So maybe having something where,
actually, repeating is
allowed or remedial education
of some kind is
provided would help.
The other question one might
ask is, is it only an urban
phenomenon or would it also
work in rural schools?
Do you need to pay the people or
could you have volunteers?
Would it be sufficient to
distribute materials, if it's
a material question?
Would you be able to motivate
the teachers to do it, to
focus on the students?
Can you concentrate even more
on the basics and make even
more progress on the basics, by
not trying to do remedial
of everything, but just
focusing on learning?
So those were the questions
that Pratham had.
Those were the questions
we had.
Another question you could ask
is, on the basics, you could
ask the opposite question.
You were saying that the
students at the top, it's not
that they are exactly ready
to come to MIT.
They are still way below
grade level.
Is there something that
can be done for them?
Or does this very simple
pedagogy that Pratham has work
only for to very low
achieving kids?
So we had all these questions.
But it was many years ago.
We had a lot of time.
So we started looking at them.
So the first thing we did was
a new evaluation in Jaunpur,
in Uttar Pradesh.
In the first program, Pratham
was running this program.
And they called us
to evaluate it.
And we went and evaluated what
it is they were doing.
But with the Jaunpur program,
we were working together.
So this study is, actually,
authored by Rukmini Banerji,
along with the rest of us.
We were now all working together
to try to figure out,
can we learn more
what's going on?
So Pratham renamed the balsakhi
program as the Read
India Program.
And as they renamed it, they
shifted to focus it on
something even more basic and
simple, on reading, and tried
to spread out much more
everywhere, not focusing on
cities but also working in rural
areas and working on a
much larger scale.
So we worked in rural
Uttar Pradesh.
We had three groups of villages,
here, in Jaunpur.
One group, where we just went
to see all the parents, had
village meetings, the
women and Pratham.
We went to see the parents
and say, you know what?
There are things you can do.
You can advocate.
We can lobby for more resources
for your schools.
You can get an extra teacher
that the government will have
to pay for.
You can get scholarships,
et cetera.
That's the first treatment, to
see whether parents would be
able to engage with
the system.
The second thing we had is we
realized that parents were
overestimating how much
their kids knew.
So a first step, that Pratham
has discovered, to get people
excited about reading, is to
train parents to administer
the small Pratham test.
So you go and say,
Ben, read this.
And Ben is like staring
blankly.
And then they realize, oh, my
god, the kids can't read.
And they have been giving their
kids to the schools,
faithfully, for years, and
assuming that something would
come out of it.
And then they realize in
this exercise that
actually, not really.
So the parents prepare a report
card for the village.
And then there was a
lot of discussion.
And the third was the Read
India volunteer.
At the end of this process,
Pratham asked anybody, are
their volunteers to
learn Read India?
In this case, they
were not paid.
People just came up, boys
and girls, usually
youngish boys and girls.
They got trained by Pratham and
stared running these camps
for the students, Read
India camps.
And what did we find?
That's kind of the result in
one graph, kids who, at
baseline, could not
read anything.
And this their result
at end-line.
These three lines look the same,
control, information
only, information plus test
provided no significant
difference.
But there's a somewhat
bigger jump for
the Read India program.
That jump, you might think,
is really not that big.
So first, I have to tell
you, it's statistically
significant.
This is different than that.
But second is, this jump is only
due to 13% of kids who
actually showed up.
So only 13% of kids who couldn't
read went to the
reading camp.
So we can do the same exercise,
the same Josh
Angrist exercise that we did
for Bombay or we did for
looking at the effect of the
balsakhi, to look at the
effect of Read India.
So we divide this little
bar by 13%.
What is it going to do
to my little bar.
It's going to make it
look much bigger.
So this is what we have here.
And that's what we find.
So these are kids who couldn't
read letters at baseline.
And now I'm adding to the
control group the little bar
that have now become bigger.
And we get to exactly 100%.
So this suggests that 100% of
the kids who actually attended
the camp are able to read
letters at end-line.
So this is a program
which is trying to
get the kids to read.
And it doesn't get them to read
full paragraphs, but it
put them one level up.
And you can do the
same exercise.
Kids who were at letter levels
are able to read paragraphs
and kids who were at
paragraph level are
able to read stories.
So this is a program that,
as a program, is
tremendously effective.
But there were still some
issues, which is that very few
kids attended the camp.
Why did only 13% of kids
attend the camp?
And that is something that
was a puzzle for us.
Next time, we'll spend much more
time on why did only 13%
of kids come to the camp.
Therefore, the overall
effect was low.
Next time, we'll try
to understand that.
But today, I'll tell you what
happened when we saw this
result, which is we saw an
effective pedagogy, where, if
I managed to grab Ben by the
collar and try to inculcate
him how to read with Pratham
technique, I can do it.
He can learn letters.
But on the other hand, if it's
left to volunteers and left to
the effort of the parents,
we only managed to
get 13% of the kids.
So the next step was is it
possible to integrate this
within the school system?
Because enrollment
is already high.
Students are already a captive
audience in the school.
If we could use the teachers
to do this, then that would
work better.
So off we went.
Pratham got a bunch of money,
by the Gates and Hewlett
Foundations, to expand
the program
in about 100 districts.
That's how they reach 38
million kids today.
But they felt that they
should try and
work through the states.
And so here the trade-off was,
well, if it does work, if we
can make it work with regular
teachers, then we will have
many more kids reached.
So that's the advantage.
The 13% will become 80%.
On the other hand, the treatment
effect might go from
this very large treatment effect
we have to a much lower
treatment effect if the teachers
are not willing or
able to carry out the program.
So that's the question.
So the next experiment, we
worked in two states, Bihar
and Uttarakhand.
In the meantime, UP
got cut in two.
And Uttarakhand is one of the
big, mountainous states, a
former part of UP, very
beautiful place with
mountains and stuff.
So in Bihar, we contrasted
four models in different
state, a summer camp taught by
government teachers, trained
teachers to implement Pratham
as part of their regular
teaching, trained volunteers
roughly like the Jaunpur
model, and distribute
only the material.
Can you just distribute the
material, the textbooks, and
get an effect from that?
That would be the best, because
that's very cheap.
In Uttarakhand, we tried this
same teacher training as in
Bihar and the volunteers.
But the volunteers were put in
the school, with the idea
that, maybe, in this way,
the kids would come.
And what did we find?
What we found is that, again,
when you have the volunteer
intervention, that again works
extremely well, with effects
similar to what we
had in Jaunpur.
So what we found in Jaunpur,
we find the
same thing in Bihar.
It worked in the same way, with
not very many kids going,
but the kids who went
really benefited.
And what is interesting here
is that it's not only basic
reading level any more.
It also covers more
advanced skills.
And the gains were felt
at all levels.
So the same approach of trying
to teach what the kids don't
know, it works at reading,
but it also works at
more advanced levels.
So great.
We had a big effect
on learning.
We were happy.
However, the teacher
intervention had very, very
little effect.
So training the teachers had
very, very little effect.
There is one effect on
Hindi written tests.
So if you squint, you find a
little bit of an effect of the
teachers but, basically,
not much.
And moreover, when you put the
volunteers in the schools, the
volunteers had no effect.
In fact, what we found is when
you put the volunteers in
schools, the teacher
is absent more.
So they just stay home more.
And the volunteers start
teaching the kids.
And then it has no impact.
So what do we conclude?
Is it that the teachers are just
horrible, and they can
absolutely, never teach
anything to the kids?
Well, we don't think that's
the case, because of the
summer camp.
In the summer camp program,
it's the teachers who were
trained to teach.
A teacher had to volunteer, and
they were paid extra to
teach summer camps.
But they were still teachers.
And they were trained.
And they did it.
And the summer camp effect
was as large as
the volunteer treatment.
It means that teachers are able
to teach kids to read if
they want to.
So the problem is that it's
not that they can't.
It's that usually they
choose not to.
And why do they choose not to?
That's what we are going
to see next time.
Where are we?
We know that we can improve
the quality of education.
Because you can take a high
school graduate, train them
for two weeks, and
they can do it.
And the puzzle is that, why
is it not taken up more?
Why is it not taken up more
by the school system?
When the teacher's are trained,
it doesn't work.
Why is not taken more by
teachers themselves?
Why is it not taken more by
parents, who are not sending
their kids to the reading camp
when they have a chance?
I mean some do but
not that many.
And finally, they are
private schools.
A lot of these kids are going
to private schools.
The private schools are somewhat
more effective than
the public schools but not
tremendously more.
So why aren't the private
schools using those
techniques?
After all, nothing stops them.
They can fire the teacher if
they don't do what they do.
They are more flexible.
So why aren't the private
school adopting that?
So that's kind of where we
are, which is there is an
effective methodology, of very
effective, you know.
You can get everybody to read at
least one more level, from
where they were, in three
months of a volunteer.
We can increase their skills
by one standard deviation.
And yet this is not taken up.
So this is not the technology.
The technology exists.
But it's not adopted, neither at
the individual level nor at
the system level.
So we'll see where
we are next time.
And we'll conclude with you.
AUDIENCE: How would
you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Teachers are
very well educated.
Teachers have a BA in teaching
plus a discipline.
And it's a pretty competitive
job to get.
And it's very well paid.
But it's very well paid at
entry, and then you don't
increase much.
And you can never,
ever be fired.
So it's a very desirable job.